2001's the fast and the furious found
major success by all accounts and in the
years since
the franchise's spawn has more than left
its mark on hollywood
it has made several big screen stars
taking in both loads of money
over six billion dollars in fact and
made front page news on more than one
occasion
one of the strongest examples of this
phenomenon is the bitter feud between
two of the series biggest names
vin diesel and dwayne the rock johnson
it took hold of the media several years
ago
and seemingly re-emerged on the road to
the premiere of f9
in an interview with men's health diesel
was asked about his experience working
with johnson in previous fast and
furious installments
more specifically he discussed the part
he played in influencing johnson's
performance as luke hobbs
diesel said noting that he went the
extra mile to make hobbs come off as an
in-your-face hard-hitting character
and that he's proud of the final product
my approach at the time was a lot of
tough love to assist in getting that
performance
where it needed to be i would do
anything i'd have to do in order to get
performances in anything i'm producing
at first glance this may just sound like
vin diesel explaining an unorthodox
method to get dwayne johnson's portrayal
of luke hobbs just right
but when you consider their personal
history and various reports from their
time
working on fast and furious films
together diesel's 2021 statement is
completely recontextualized
buckle up let's ride through their rocky
relationship
this story begins on august 8th 2016
when johnson made a since-deleted
instagram post to voices displeasure
with someone on the face of the furious
set
he altered an unnamed person for acting
unprofessional
and not backing up their behavior
clarifying that he was on good terms
with most of the cast and crew otherwise
he wrote when you watch this movie next
april and it seems like i'm not acting
in some of these scenes and my blood is
legit boiling
you're right naturally this opened up
speculation over who he's referring to
even more naturally various news outlets
ran with this developing story and
spread the common belief that vin diesel
was the person johnson was not so subtly
pointing the finger at according to tmz
the two parties met up for a secret
meeting
on august 9 2016 in hopes of putting
their anger to rest
adding that the fate of the furious cast
was unhappy with johnson for causing a
stir at the tail end of the chute
apparently the clash stemmed from
diesel's position as a producer
and is penchant for making changes that
drew the ire of his coaster
later an anonymous source close to the
project told people that the tension
between the actors had been on the rise
for months
a common complaint was johnson's
apparent lack of punctuality
sometimes not appearing at all and
stalling production this angered diesel
but he was far from absolved of any
wrongdoing
other reports claimed he would engage in
similar behavior even locking himself in
his trailer during the filming of
furious 7.
as word of the budding rivalry began to
spread johnson hopped back on instagram
to try and quell any further rumors
about him
diesel or anyone else connected to the
fast and furious name
once again addressing the onset
animosity but highlighting that the
ability to work past it
is what really matters and like with any
team that's a family there's going to be
conflicts
family is going to have differences of
opinion and fundamental core beliefs
to me conflict can be a good thing when
it's followed by great resolution
come august 19th vin diesel took to
facebook to speak directly on the
subject
showing his appreciation for the fans
for their support and letting them know
that
without you i would not be doing fast
date he then detailed their involvement
in johnson landing the hob's role to
begin with
revealing we gave the role that was
originally written for tommy lee jones
we gave it to dwayne and he shined in it
it seems all that sunny chatter didn't
make it all the way to johnson
he made a post of his own that same day
on instagram he announced it wrapped up
on the fate of the furious with a
caption thanking numerous people
involved in making the project a reality
guess who he didn't mention
yup vin diesel though few doubted
johnson and diesel weren't at odds their
fellow
fate of the furious star michelle
rodriguez set the record straight she
told people in september 2016
any human being who knows what men are
like knows to stay out of those
situations
and let them figure it out nevertheless
she clarified that the two were friends
even in the face of their heated
conflict
and would put aside their differences
sooner rather than later
months later the press tour for face of
the furious was in full swing
and diesel expressed his love and
appreciation for johnson
he told usa today on april 7th 2017
i don't think the world really realizes
how close we are in a weird way in my
house he's uncle dwayne
two days later on entertainment tonight
johnson posited that his issues with
diesel boiled down to different
philosophies
and that the most important thing about
juncture was the film itself
with that tmc reported on april 18th
that the two were once again
on good terms and that their beef was
officially squashed
with all of this backstory in mind could
vin diesel's most recent quip about the
rock and his acting abilities reopen old
wounds
you can bet that johnson's cooking up a
response for sure we can practically
smell it now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
acting rivals are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one